the numbers are as follows badnock 49
bravoman 27
mordent 83
sunak 101
truss
64
tugandat
32 therefore under the rules suella
bravaman
is eliminated from the
contest and the others are able to go
forward
to a further ballot on
monday thank you there you go uh the
results are in the person who has been
eliminated is suella brotherman her vote
actually going down uh from 32 in the
first ballot to 27 uh today you can see
there rishi cena clearing uh the hundred
mark on 101 penny mordent in second
place again on 83 liz truss
on 64. can we bad enough on 49
increasing her boat share
there and you can see there tom tugger
hat just speaking through on 32 his vote
number going down too let's go to our
political editor beth rigby what do you
make of the results
well um that that's that's an
interesting set of results look what
bravaman is out so
that is one candidate out and she
dropped votes she went back five and tom
tugan hat he is still in there but he's
also lost votes and you have to ask
yourself
at this point does tom tugan hat decide
to fold now
sources around him insisted to me that
that had not been a conversation that
had had that he was very keen to go into
any live tv debates if he could but
let's see what tom tugan now does he's
losing support that is not where you
want to be but look at the main runners
rishi sunak has got over a hundred he
now is only 19 votes away
from
getting to that magic 120 figure and
he's put on what let me 13 votes so he's
taken a chunk of that 43 that split
maybe maybe not as much as he might have
wanted but anyway look he's over the 100
mark what's interesting with morden is
she's put on another
let me try and do the math 16 votes
so she'll be happy with that i think
she's still in second place she's gone
up to the mid-80s or the low 80s and
trust i think what you can see there
she's put on 14 votes she's still
quite clearly trailing morden not
managing to close the gap but isn't it
interesting sophie that bravaman had
lost five votes and it seems to me that
as sam was talking about earlier uh that
suela bravo and some of those candidates
may be moving to try and bolster liz
trust but she's still uh clearly in
third place i mean i think from those
results we have to see uh where brother
man where the rest of those votes go you
would think that they would perhaps lean
uh towards a trust candidate uh rather
than a mordant candidate given that
penny more than what a conviction
brexiteer is more progressively liberal
uh on on the sort of liberal
conservative wing on the party when it
comes to social policy so i'm not sure
bravo man supporters would think that
penny mordant is their woman but mordent
will be pleased with that sonic will be
relieved to get over a hundred and trust
there
she really does have to make up some
ground because looking at those numbers
when we talk about whether rishi sunak
can lend votes in order to block other
people
you've got to be really comfortably over
the 120 mark to risk in the later rounds
lending votes out i would say from that
liz trust
looking in a bit of trouble as penny
morden becomes after two rounds the
clear second favorite to sonak